We'll just cut you off.
I got to train more.
Kill me.
So fucking it is so cut off so you could keep training.
Wow.
So Nick and him,
they've got some screws loose,
but they're committed.
How committed are you that you want to achieve this goal?
This dream,
his dream.
He grew up in New Jersey.
He's like,
I want to be a wrestler and so I'm going to,
I'm going to do this incredibly inspirational guy.
So him and 12 other guys came over to our airbnb and we watched the fights and
it was controversial Khabib and we loved watching everything that night and then
whenever that happened.
Um,
so I'm torn on it because I love those guys as fighters,
absolutely love them as fighters.
Um,
and then whenever that happened to just something that in me,
I don't,
I don't know if I was embarrassed or if I was disappointed,
but they were introducing some guys,
uh,
Steve Weatherford who played for the New York giants.
He came over for like a,
he played for the giants for like 10 or 12 years,
um,
lives in San Diego.
Great Guy.
But he's not a big MMA fan.
So I was explaining everything to him and when that happened is just pretty
disappointing.
Then I spoke at,
um,
at,
uh,
anti bullying coalition in Tulsa and I went there and there's a girl there that,
she looked real sweet,
real quiet,
introverted,
um,
and she worked with mental health and her name was alley.
All of a sudden she found out I was an MMA fighter and she said,
oh my gosh,
you know,
my husband's a huge MMA fan.
I'm not at all.
I never really even sat down and watched it with him.
But then he decided to take me to the t-mobile arena for the,
her first fight was Conor,
Khabib and uh,
she was in there and she said she loved it before that Michelle Waterson was an
incredible inspiration to her,
her saying that she wants to be the first mom to be a UFC champion.
She said it,
the night was going great,
and then whenever that happened she said it was,
it literally scared her because fight started popping off to the right over
leftover behind her.
She sent out,
poured out into their arena.
Um,
and so that was her first introduction to May.
So I was a little tough to see,
but at the same time,
I get it.
Like those emotions are flaring.
And you were talking about it too,
and,
uh,
kind of your perspective of martial artists and,
yeah,
I mean,
same thing that,
that you were feeling.
Just,
you know,
that little bit of kind of sadness and disappointment of,
the,
the biggest event,
the most views,
the most people watching.
And that's the last thing that they see.
That's what they,
you know,
go to bed thinking about and feeling about.
And,
and I just,
you know,
I don't think,
uh,
even Keven Connor,
it could be,
that's not who they are as martial artists,
you know,
uh,
sure.
All the emotions were flying and they,
you know,
they have a history and,
and it's hard to let that go,
but I,
I just don't,
I don't feel like that's even who they really are.
You see in all their other fights,
uh,
they,
they respect their opponents.
You know,
I'm gonna disagree with you.
Um,
I mean,
look,
Connor,
that's what he does.
Yeah.
He Talk Shit to people and fucks with their head.
I mean it's,
it's a giant part of his game and I know that that was part of the strategy of
him throwing that Dolly
at the bus.
That shit's way out of line.
I mean,
throwing a Dolly at the bus,
that's not what a martial artist does.
When you,
when you,
if you stop and think about what we value about martial arts and turns of
teaching children honor when we were respect and discipline and the,
the things,
when we think of as a classical martial artists like Leo to Machida or something
like that,
bowing to their opponent that does not,
this is,
this is theatrical [inaudible].
This is hype.
But in all fairness,
the UFC used that to sell that fight.
I mean,
there was a big part of their promotional campaign was seeing Connor throw the
Dolly at the bus and the screaming,
the yelling,
you know,
you're setting,
you're setting an exam.
There's something going on outside of the actual contest itself.
There's all this extra credit,
curricular violence,
right?
There's throwing a dollar at a bus shattering in the window.
All these guys running and screaming,
get off the bus and then they're promoting this.
They're showing this,
and then everyone's shocked.
Then it escalates after the fight itself.
You know,
one of the,
in some ways,
one of the more interesting moments of the fight was Khabib on top ICAN or
beaten the shit out of him going,
let's talk now.
Have you seen that video?
Yeah.
That's fucking terrifying.
It's like,
come on,
let's talk.
Bam.
And he's just slamming them.
Told him he's got to do that before the fight too.
I mean,
yeah,
we're going to talk.
We're going to talk when I'm on top of you and you're tired and I'm beating the
fuck out of you.
That's what we're going to talk.
And that's what he did.
You know,
this is all not what could be does.
This is outside of his,
his,
if you look at his standard behavior,
he's very respectful.
I mean,
he's never had an incident like this ever in a fight.
All of his fights before that,
or him shaking his opponent's hand,
doing the standard stare down standard stuff,
talking about his skill set and what he's gonna do.
And there's no disrespect.
There's no insults.
There's none of this.
That's what I mean about Khabib.
Yeah,
but not Connor.
I mean,
this is a,
but,
but here's the other thing.
On the other side,
it makes it fun.
I'm very torn because all the shit that he talked to,
Josie Aldo,
look,
that was a big factor.
And Josie Aldo charging at him losing his composure face first and getting clip
at that left hand.
That's a big factor is the emotional anx that he had gone through from months
and months on the road with this guy.
The middle of warfare.
Yeah.
I mean that mental warfare is a real thing.
It just didn't work with Khabib.
He'd have the opposite effect and with could be.
He's like,
I can't wait to get my fucking hands on you.
It wasn't,
I can't believe this guy's saying these things to me with could be bad,
but it ramped up the violence to the point where he was letting you know like,
Hey,
this is real to me.
Like if you,
if you want to act thuggish and we'll just keep going,
we'll just,
I'll tell you,
I'll keep taking this.
Like he didn't want to stop after Connor tapped,
like he was holding onto him and he's letting them know,
hey motherfucker,
like this is real.
This is not just shit talking.
Connor was saying to him,
this is just business.
It's just business.
And he's like,
let's talk now.
Let's talk now.
Like he,
he's like,
this is not business to him.
So to him fights,
I mean this is what he said in the press conference.
It should be,
this is a respect sport and this should just,
sports should be about two men expressing themselves to the best of their
physical ability inside the cage,
just doing their best against the best fighters in the world.
And that should speak for itself and that they should have respect and honor
outside of it.
I wish you would have had the chance to say that,
you know,
we didn't have a chance.
The sad part was him letting the emotions take over what he felt and instead of
just getting the belt tied on and kind of killing them with kindness at the end
and saying that,
having that chance to put that in everyone's minds and ears.
He did in the post fight interview.
But I mean how many are the post fight press conference.
But how many people got a chance to see that?
I mean just a few thousand I'm sure.
And as in comparison to the 2.4 million,
the download,
the paper view and the many,
many,
many more that saw you to eclipse and Instagram's clips.
Yeah,
I mean everybody saw it.
It's,
it's unfortunate but it's also a financial windfall.
Like it's like the whole thing.
It's weird because part of what makes Connor so interesting is that he's so good
at talk that shit.
He's hilarious and he knows how to back it up.
But when we saw him fight Khabib,
he just,
he fell short.
But it's really that simple when skill versus skill.
He felt short and the the,
the shit talking led to Qbe Being v taking it very personal and very personal at
the end and pointing a Dylan Dennis and jumping off the top of the cage.
The whole thing was just,
it's so fucking crazy.
But the idea that people should be surprised after Connor frozen Dolly at the
bus and then still winds up able to fight.
I mean just,
what did he do?
Paid some money.
Did some,
I mean he's got to do some,
some service.
What does he does community service.
I don't even know what he has to do.
I don't either.
It was something that's where it's not.
Yeah,
it's Kinda crazy.
Me throwing a Dolly is fucking way worse.
Then punching a guy who punches people for a living,
which is done.
Dennis is a professional fighter.
He's a professional fighter.
He jumps out,
he takes a swing at them,
they're screaming.
He and Dylan is like,
fuck you.
And he's like,
And there's a bunch of people get involved and then a bunch of other people jump
in.
The whole thing was nuts.
But the idea that we should be shocked after him throwing a Dolly at a bus
because Khabib's on the bus that those Russians don't fucking play like that
man.
This video is afterwards when Doug Stone,
where they're shooting up uzis and they can 47.
So I wrestled there,
uh,
when I was like 18,
um,
wrestled there and it was crazy.
They were taking us around everywhere in g wagons and the ones in front of us
had like armed,
uh,
I don't know,
machine guns on top of them.
The one behind us are machine guns on top of them.
Um,
and then what was it?
We were,
we were walking through one of the streets and there's these big chains that are
in between the road and the sidewalk and we're walking down the sidewalk and all
of a sudden there's like a laser that comes over and,
uh,
and our guys are like,
we gotta go,
we gotta go.
All of a sudden a car came up onto the sidewalk,
started driving like they're going to play us down.
We had to jump into the road to not get hit.
And uh,
I,
I don't know why that happened,
but after that we weren't allowed our,
uh,
the hotel we were in,
we had like balconies to where we could look out,
well,
they had to move our rooms to where we're inside to where we couldn't have a
balcony and everything else to where the,
the,
just because of that threat,
because of the laser that came because of the truck that came up onto the
sidewalk and tried to run us over,
there was some crazy rumor that someone got arrested outside of the t mobile
arena.
See if that's true.
If someone got arrested with a gun outside the t mobile arena on after the fight
or during the fight because it was,
there was some sort of crazy talk about threats.
The problem is you don't know how much of that's bullshit.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
I probably should have researched that before we talked about it,
but you see anything bullshit out of,
did they post that?
You know,
I heard the same thing though.
I heard.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think I heard it on Instagram,
but yeah,
they don't play around their honors.
Yeah.
Different world man.
Especially Dagestan that's all hard part of the country.
Not the Dublin isn't hard,
but it's like that.
They're not known for their,
uh,
humor and shit.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
well I went into a store,
I went into a store,
like a little market and I was whistling and Dagestan and I didn't know that
that was something disrespectful,
but someone came right up behind me and just slap me on the back of the head.
Like,
Whoa,
hold them.
I'd probably like,
it could be just dad came up and I knew that he was a bad dude,
so I wasn't going to do anything.
I just didn't know translator had to come up and say,
you don't whistle in public,
you know,
Oh,
you're having a good day,
then I can't even whistle that good.
But,
uh,
but it was just kind of whistling and myself,
I didn't even know I was doing it.
Yeah,
that's probably that,
that's probably that they don't show the bottom of your feet.
Like if you,
uh,
that's for sure you can Google that.
But if you are sitting there and you like cross your legs and you show the
bottom of your foot,
that's culturally really disrespectful to show,
um,
the,
yeah,
bottoms of your shoes or your,
the bottom of your feet.
So they just don't play around there.
Um,
and then,
so if you have your,
like your foot on top of your thigh like this,
don't do that.
Don't do that.
Someone would come and slap your leg and you make sure your feet are both on the
ground.
Just a lot of cultural stuff.
That's why they're so tough.
Always climbing up those mountains.
Uh,
I mean it's just jagged mountains.
I remember it as one of the most beautiful places I've ever been.
I'm just stunning.
But just the,
the hard life.
Did you see that?
A Nike or,
sorry,
not Nike,
but Reebok video that could beep did as it was.
It was awesome.
But just seeing that that's,
that's the real life there.
It's,
there's a photo of him that he posted a on his Instagram with his father,
him and his father standing right after the fight.
He did it like to explain like that this,
this what this is about to him.
His honor.
It's not about money.
It's about honor and respect and it's a photo of him standing with his father
with this incredible mountain range behind him.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a different part of the world.
So that,
that strategy with Connor backfired.
But do you think there's a point where,
uh,
you know,
the set is,
that's incredible.
What a photo that they should say,
hey,
let's,
let's turn the talking down a little bit.
That's what,
that's what got Connor to the dance.
I mean,
it's one of the reasons why it has escalated.
It has to then Mayweather bringing in his dad and the assault and different
stuff like that and then could be going after his religion,
right?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
So it's,
it's gotten,
it's almost like he has to,
I think you were saying that this,
he's got one up ourself.
Right.
And,
and for me it just kind of felt like,
you know,
it wasn't a surprise.
It was kind of like the Karma for the UFC promoting the bus and you know,
and,
and letting it just keep getting deeper and deeper.
You know,
say it's the story and it is the story,
but at a certain point if it's something that was illegal hurt somebody,
maybe you don't use that.
I was honestly shocked that they were using it and promotion.
I was like,
wow,
I shouldn't be shocked.
I thought that when I saw the promo and I saw the,
the,
the Dolly flying at the bus and then the video from the inside with the glass
shattering,
I was like,
okay,
I guess I shouldn't be shocked because it did happen.
You know,
it is a part of the story,
but I mean,
is this,
is this encouraging this,
like what is,
I mean,
they're using it to sell the biggest fight in the history of the sport turned
out to be true.
It is the biggest fight and the history of the sport.
Is that good?
That doesn't seem good,
but it seems,
it seems from my perspective,
but it's,
you know,
it's intertainment versus sport,
right.
When it comes to sport,
like you would never use that to,
to advertise the Olympics.
Right?
Right.
They would never have an assault to advertise the Olympics.
But this is something different.
It's commerce.
There's a lot of money involved.
It's a,
it's a huge cultural spectacle.
It's Conor Mcgregor,
who's,
he transcends sport.
He's this superstar in just the world of just show business.
So it's different but different.
But yeah.